belief is evidence it is subjective
evidence you've chosen to believe about
yourself we're all in a self-belief
spiral upwards or downwards some people
are negatively reinforcing and what I
mean by that is they're approaching the
challenge at work of speaking on stage
with skepticism and fear therefore they
show up badly and even if they do a good
job because of that frame they interpret
they did a bad job which erodes their
self-esteem which means next time they
show up with even more pessimism if they
even raise their hand to show up and
it's this downward spiral since 10 I've
been on the opposite I've been on the
upward spiral
tried something could be that the
business I started at 10 or 12 years old
it went well which meant that next time
I showed up with more optimism and
belief which meant it was more likely to
go well and even if it didn't I
interpreted it well and since 10 I've
been like that and from that has I've
recuited a lot of knowledge because I've
been failing fast